it is so lovely to meet you Anna I
adored this film I just missed it at
Overlook Film Festival back in the
spring so I was so excited to get to
talk to you about it it's such a good
representation of like what it's like to
just be a woman existing you know now
which is not something you see a lot in
horror movies totally I really
appreciate that that was the goal I
guess you know just that perspective
coming through and I'm so stoked that
you liked it yeah I in a weird kind of
way the the first version of the
appendage the little one is kind of cute
to me in a weird way and I was gonna ask
you where I could get one but then I
realized I'm on Lexa Pro to prevent that
exact thing from happening I feel you I
totally feel you but I agree I think
she's real cute we got a little replica
over here oh I love
it I adorable as
well yeah but with with a you know
that's a practical you know piece both
the little one and then all the way up
to the big one does that present any
challenges for you as a filmmaker having
that piece in there or is it much easier
than having say a CG little thing coming
out of her side you know both have their
own challenges practical effects I would
say definitely
present A Time Challenge on set and also
just pre-production challenges in a way
where it's like no no we can't fix it in
post so we got to fix it in
pre-production and we have to rehearse
and make time for that and make sure
it's okay and you know one of our stages
I think it's stage two had six
puppeteers as well as someone doing the
voice as well as somebody like
controlling the eyebrows and you know I
mean it is it is no joke it is serious
business but to me it's really really
worth it because the effect of it is so
visceral and I I just haven't really
felt that way yet with CGI in my own
taste bubble yeah and I know speaking of
the appendage and then of the voice I
spoke spoke to Emily Hampshire earlier
this year and she does the voice for the
first sort of two iterations of it so
how did that come about she totally
surprised me with that we were
auditioning for the voice and I had done
all the temp voice stuff for the rough
cut and I was like I just cannot hear
this anymore like please let's just get
someone else in here and uh Emily I was
like looking through the auditions and
then I was like Emily Hampshire like
what is she doing in here like what's
going on and then I played it and it was
unbelievable and it was really really
cool you know like she did something so
different with it that I was surprised
with and it was a lot of like Moaning
Myrtle action in the auditions and she
really brought this Cadence to it that
was super grounded and unique yeah and I
love the parallels it creates between
her being the voice of of her of the
original appendage and then Claudia at
the end totally to we talked about that
too it's like the subconscious thing
where it's like all those voices are
eating at Hannah in like a crazy way
yeah and I know that this film started
off off as a short for bite-sized
Halloween but before you even got to
finish the short you got the green light
for the full film so in terms of sort of
expanding that concept from what you saw
in the short you know what was that
process like because it's such a large
expansion on you know where this
appendage comes from yes yes and it was
a challenge you know it's like how do
you turn this into a feature and and for
me it was always about having that
understanding of anxiety and depression
of it's not just work that it's going to
affect it's going to affect your
relationships your friendships and you
know your core childhood traumas
eventually get into that with the parent
stuff and so that was always kind of The
Guiding Light in terms of how to expand
it and it's just so lucky like I feel so
lucky that they yeah they came on set
for the short and they were like this is
cool your team is awesome we like you
let's make a feature and it was it was
really cool in the sense too that it was
so fast that I didn't really get to edit
myself too much you know like sometimes
you got that again that appendage editor
voice in your in your head that's like I
don't know if this idea is good enough
just throw it away and you know who
knows how many good ideas are thrown
away because you just edit yourself out
of them too early yeah yeah and when you
premiered this film at South by
Southwest you mentioned that it was at
least partially inspired by an exercise
from your therapist of saying take your
anxiety out of yourself and make it into
a separate character so when you're
dealing with anxiety as a filmmaker and
you know that it being such a direct
parallel with this story does that add
an extra layer of stress or is it
cathartic to say know I can get all of
this out through this weird little being
thing I think it's both I think the
level of how person I mean it's not
autobiographical like obviously I don't
have an appendage but it's emotionally
very personal and I think it is both
stressful and cathartic and I do think
that my favorite movies you can sense
that in the film where you're like okay
this filmmaker is like going through a
thing I can feel it it's connecting with
me and so it was worth the stress of
making it personal that way if that
makes sense yeah is anxiety something
you want to kind of continue to Grapple
with in your work going forward or is it
like okay I can stick this one back on
the bookshelf and we we can be done with
it and I can go explore other things
yeah I think I you know I think it's
like the movie itself where it is just
going to be a thing for a while like in
the movies that I want to explore and
whether it's anxiety or depression or
other mental health stuff it always I
always am just like o yes I want to talk
about this and I think there's still a
bit of a void with that in like there's
grief there's all these other trauma
based stuff but I'm really curious about
just exploring mental health and horror
yeah which I think is is something
that's coming sort of more to the
Forefront now and it's you know as
somebody who is anxious all of the time
it's a nice thing to sit down and watch
it and kind of feel for maybe an hour
and a half that you know maybe things
aren't as bad as you know Hannah has it
totally totally and it's like oh we can
like talk about this like it's okay to
talk about this and I'm sure you know
it's fun to go to screenings and people
walk we've had two screenings and people
walk out and they're like like you know
I actually have anxiety too and I was
like yes we all do it's and you
mentioned the sort of ending of the film
and I'm dying to talk about it because
it kind of caught me off guard and I I
interpret it I interpreted it as Hannah
kind of finally learning to take care of
her mental health and you know be gentle
with it is that the way that you're that
it's supposed to be interpreted or are
you kind of a no happy endings in horror
movies person I definitely think you
nailed it spot on yeah I in the whole
movie is you know mapped out that way
where she's so ashamed the entire time
and she's locking it up in basements and
closets and she doesn't want anyone to
see it and that obviously doesn't work
and I think that that contend shame can
make things so much worse and so you
know that was always the ending I had in
mind and you know some people would be
like she should kill it or whatever but
I don't know if that's realistic and you
know I think that it's its own weird
kind of Bittersweet happy sad ending in
a way where it's we got to coexist and
love it like you said yeah you can't get
rid of it you just got to learn to learn
to deal with it absolutely I remember
like taking a break from therapy and I
was like yeah I got rid of it I like
came back and my therapist was like dude
no like you can't get rid of it you just
have to have tools to deal with it and
coexist with it and learn exactly yeah
yeah so one last question for you I love
like learning about the horror movies
that have influenc people so was were
there any that were particular
Inspirations for this film absolutely
the fly cron and the fly was a big one
um I think that might be one of my
favorite horror movies ever and Julia du
coro's raw we watched that well we were
shooting Black
Swan uh I think that was like Hannah's
movie in her head that she was having
you know what I mean so that was a big
character one for her and um you know I
watched after hours this Chris say the
after hours while we were shooting this
which is not a horror movie but it is
kind of that like absurdest Spiral of
things going wrong that I think kind of
bled into the movie yeah cuz it does
feel a little bit like an absurdist
fairy tale like I was trying to describe
this movie to my family and they're like
and you liked that I was like yes of
course because it it it does as absurd
as it is existing as a woman in the
world is absurd so absurd it's so absurd
and even like the thoughts that we have
are it's like when you take a step back
you're like that was wow okay like that
was a thing that's crazy and funny and
wild yeah awesome well thank you so much
for talking with me today this has been
a wonderful conversation I'm so glad we
finally met like face to face yeah great
thank you for having me thank
you